-I'm so happy.
-I am so happy.
-I am a giant --
I'm a big fan and I love you,
so I'm so happy
you're here in person.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you for being --
-I'm so happy, Jimmy,
to be here.
-Thank you so much.
"No Time to Die" is finally out.
-Yes.
-I think Daniel Craig was on
our show twice promoting it,
and it kept getting...
-I'm a bit jealous.
-...pushed.
No, oh, my gosh.
Please come back.
But I mean --
Now it's finally out,
and I got to see it,
and you are fantastic
in this film.
-Well, thank you.
-It is a -- it's a beautiful --
I mean, obviously,
it's a James Bond film,
so there's action.
It's a thriller.
It's spy.
You don't know anything.
It's just gorgeously shot.
And then it's just --
it's just everything.
It's the whole package.
I don't think they make movies
like this anymore.
I mean, there's --
nothing against movies with CGI
and all that,
but you could tell
these are real stunts
and real people
doing these stunts,
and it's like, if you do two
takes of this, like,
"Oh, this is gonna cost us."
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
It's like, "Let's just please do
one take of this."
Do you get nervous if you have
a big explosion or something,
like if you mess up a line
or something?
-Oh, yeah.
I'm very nervous.
-You are?
-Yeah, always.
-Really?
-Yeah. You can tell, no?
Look, I'm so red.
-No!
You don't -- I hear you.
You're gorgeous.
-Thank you.
-Here's you on the red carpet.
This is at the London premiere
of "No Time to Die."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, that's hype.
Come on.
Now at the premiere,
the Royal Family were there.
-Yeah, yeah.
We were in the box with them.
-And what did it feel like?
-It was really nice,
because, you know, finally
the film came out
and we had to postpone
several times.
So, to feel the excitement
in the theater was great.
-I -- Yeah.
-It was just -- Yeah.
-And had you seen any cuts of
the film and stuff like --
or the final film before
that or...?
-So, I saw bits of it,
but it was the first time
that I really saw the film,
you know?
-In the theater.
-Yeah, yeah, it was great.
-Just even at the beginning
when the --
[ Sings "James Bond Theme" ]
I'm like -- I almost
started crying right there.
I was like, "Oh!"
I was so excited.
-You've seen the film, but you
can't talk about it, right?
-I actually can't say anything.
-Yeah.
And I would never do that.
I would never --
-Yeah. That's good.
-[ French accent ] No spoiler.
-Yeah, no spoiler, please.
Don't say anything.
-[ Normal ] Yeah,
don't say anything.
But, I mean, can you maybe
tell us a little something
about the...?
-I mean, you've seen
the film, right?
-Yeah.
-So, yeah, I can tell you
a few things,
like, for example,
you know when --
[ Speaking French ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Smooches ]
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I do remember that, yeah.
Yeah, well, yeah, of course.
I do remember that part, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
that was beautiful.
Yeah, you didn't give
too much away.
-A lot of action.
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly how
you sum it up right there.
You're phenomenal.
And I just thought
it was so interesting, too,
to be James Bond -- obviously
all of these movies,
but to be his love interest
in two movies.
-Yeah.
-It's rare. You don't see that.
-What did it feel like
coming back?
-I mean, she's --
This time, she's a more complex
woman, you know?
But she's a real woman.
Like a simple woman.
She has -- She had
a difficult upbringing.
Her mother is an alcoholic.
Her father is an assassin.
She falls in love with a killer.
But she's a normal woman,
you know?
-[ Laughs ]
Everyone can relate, yeah.
A lot of people can relate.
-You can relate to her easily.
-But it is tricky, your role.
And it's -- And when you see
this, you go like --
'cause I thought "Spectre," too.
I go, "Ooh, that was good,
and it was tricky."
But this one --
-Yeah, but "Spectre,"
we didn't really know her.
She was more mysterious.
-Yeah.
-This time, we really
get to know her.
-You dive in and -- Oh, my gosh,
you're just phenomenal.
I'm so happy that you're here.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Léa Seydoux
and Daniel Craig
in "No Time to Die."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Open the door.
Open the door!
Don't.
-What is it?
-James, you...
you don't know what this is...
to bring me to this.
Please.
-All right, open the doors.
Open the door.
-Open it.
[ Door beeps, unlocks ]
-Where are you going?
-Home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh!
Léa Seydoux, everybody!